what's up folks Daniel Dwight here
suplex City also known as New York City
downright good hey doing hey that's what
they call it suplex City yeah that's
we're here to see the latest stubby W
video game WWE 2k 17 I played some in
the back for a little while not many
characters on offer time who did you
pick right picked Shunsuke Nakamura who
did you pick alex navaro AJ Styles nice
I picked Finn Balor the Irishman okay
yeah the pride of Ireland except yes
he's very good the call is gonna rip
once once this whole wrestling things
finished up it's gonna have a great
political career who's the most famous
Irishman Sheamus how's your Irish doing
it's okay Coppola [ __ ] Coppola [ __ ] oh
that's it not really unfortunate I mean
khonanesta saw to come Argus to hane the
better come on freshen we're gonna talk
about video games and we we played one
today and Dan what did you think of your
time with WWE 2k 17 it felt like a
slightly improved version of the last
couple I kind of put was a 15 and 16 in
the same boat of like okay we have this
brief resurgence of 13 and 14 being
pretty damn good especially 13 and then
15 I thought was terrible and 16 was
marginally better I feel like this is
marginally better than that which I
guess we can say we're moving in the
right direction little hard to tell with
the sort of very restricted demo we saw
today Alex yeah there wasn't a lot in
that demo the backstage stuff was there
and there was a limited number of
wrestlers like Nakamura and some of
those guys I will say that the base
animation stuff seems better like I was
watching Seth Rollins get his ass kicked
pretty handily and he was making the
right faces like he was the right kind
of exaggerated oh god what's happening
to me kind of thing if that stuff looked
pretty good everyone say in the
backstage stuff like Ike straight-up
walked into a different room picked up
an LCD television and then walked back
ends in Harlem
beep somebody I forget her was quite
quite badly with it yeah the best detail
of that is when you walk between the
rooms in the background there's like a
wrestler and a woman like talking to
each other and no matter what you do
they don't stop talking like they're
just kind of standing in the background
just having their little conversation oh
no we ran up there and they ran away oh
you did okay cuz what I watched was just
like you would get in the vicinity and
they would just kind of sit there lose
keep talking you know they were really
care deine you interviewed some
superstars first of all I wanna talk to
you about your time with mr. Lesnar yeah
it was yeah I think he might be calling
oh we know that's not have no we were
gonna meet up later for some burgers or
something but yeah great guy just really
friendly love people it's amazing how
you're able to connect the wrestlers on
this personal level could you
realistically at five account I have
before yes yeah you know I just feel
like I'm one of them I feel like me and
Brock Lesnar Sarah in common and you
know we have that kinship from the word
go so you know yeah yeah I hope who else
did you talk to a doctor Enzo and Cass
who are great we're locals
yeah that's all I talked to them about
what's weird local New Jersey / New York
stuff and they're great thank you so
much for joining me I'm just wonderful
wrestling here's baby that's you w daily
2k is 17 coming to a console near you
real soon he's pulling out all the stops
tonight